Ramadan Vlog in einem Feiertag mit
weniger als 5 Stunden Schlaf habe ich
mich ins Auto gesetzt und wir haben das
schon mal die Sitzheizung vorgewärmt das
sind die kleinen Dinge im Leben dann
waren wir im Online Shop denn wir hatten
einen Termin mit unserem Partner der
kommt nämlich aus dem Bella Italia der
ist extra angeflogen gekommen wir waren
dann auch noch im Ruhrpark das Café
hatte geöffnet alle anderen hatten zu
aber wir hatten trotzdem sehr sehr viele
Gäste und ich habe mich gefreut wieder
ein paar von euch getroffen zu haben
gegen Nachmittag haben wir unseren
Partner verabschiedet der ist
zurückgeflogen nach Italien und ich
hatte so Lust auf einen Cappuccino ich
liebe diese Kaffeemaschine habe mir dann
den Espresso aus dem Store geholt der
schmeckt wirklich Schokolade den haben
uns mit nach Hause genommen damit ich
mir später gönnen kann und hier zeige
ich euch mal meine super fancy Brille
die seit über drei Jahren kaputt aber
ich komme nicht dazu sie zu reparieren
und fast ein bisschen gab es wieder mein
fette Thomas Leute ich muss euch das
Rezept geben meine Eltern waren da und
wir haben uns auch dieses super leckere
Dessert gegangen jetzt heißt es wieder
Küche aufräumen und ich habe keinen Bock
aber ich muss dadurch dass ich morgen
weniger zu tun habe tschüss